味は全然違うんだけども見た目が全く一緒に飲み物っていうの僕ここ数年間ずっと探し
続けておりまして最近ようやく気づきましたご覧くださいまず空徳ちゃんあのおいしい
じゃ美味しいですけどねちょっと
やっぱり痩せるのようなでちょっと味の方はねまぁこれ遠く茶の色ですね
続いてこのトークちゃんねまったく
にだと思われるなものか発見したんですよちょっとなぞるの経験値と思ったんですが
こちらでございますもう太る会まずいい
応力デブだったぽい曲は同じわけないと思ったんですけどよく見かけるがないね
製作所でこちらも普通ですね
me
うん全克ようなちょっとほらの釣果と言います多分心当たりあるのはこっちから得
ツアーのジャスミンティーと多い
おっちゃちゃんと時間の日かするんですよ多い音でつけてみましょう
japan じゃないもうやばいっ
うわぁ
じゃ世民
てす
失敗じゃあお前が一番だろ
ています
いや渦はでもかっきりなく使いですこれ選べるご覧ください
いやどっちなんだろうジャスパーっていうのが近いのかな
いやでもこんなパッと見ではなと思うんですよねいやーこれっ
なぜからいいんじゃないかん
してきたきたきたきだけど歯が抜けましたね重いお茶ロックにジャスミンティー読んで
あるとモンスターエナジーと全く同じ色になることが今
わかりました
イヤホン等の簡易てきたと思うんですけども天と地の差でて飲み物買いのかパワー
あふれる範囲に入った感じと変更しここない太陽と月の戦いみたいな感じになると思い
ましたためでビビる dx んだと思う人がして皆さんトップ茶飲んでもう2位何時
だったらどうなので落ち着こうと思ったに変えになっちゃう心がねしなかって
気絶すると思いますで朝食やっていきましょう
おっちゃ
入っという入り早速ターゲットに親善あ流れでをターン渡してもんだ瞬間もただった時
でやっていこうと思いますでは
いたせい
を表示
やっぱです
ています
保存ですよ
[音楽]
また別ないっちゃべちゃん
バローロちゃん大泣きかさっきん
きっ
もないん
1個えっの分散化って言ったじゃん
はっ
もんだ
や二匹が使うそう
で声声声と普通
以前には強国という
不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不不
全然レッドブルやこれはーはっはっは
めっちゃ似てないいや受かっトナーやわけないぱっと見お茶で空いてるから
あゴッド何度やばいも入れたんからかなんかの見かけはたしていきたいかなと思ったら
入ってるか持ったなぁ
[音楽]
そうですねありがとうございましたのですかっ
小坂タウンだけですねうんん
そうですね何で
あのうこの肇社長のパワーを使って
[音楽]
アニメ見て泣けるアニメをたくさん見て
ちょっと人としての優しくなって皆さん
ん
的なんです
さあ
さあ本人そしてターゲットの要望はリボン一度やらせば増で撮ってみたいてくださいと
ストップするます実況はどっち肇社長がを務めさせていただいておりますさあ今
う子ちゃんと見せかけた方最多10月ターゲットのもとに置かれますいかに自然な顔で
二マークが今回のポイントは皆さん魔力供給を見て問題ないと確認している家がせ突起
日本人乗り役所として周りが胸像がスポット
お大事となっておりますサーマルで当たり前のようにスマホを弄りマークし前の動作
さあお前はそれを多治見市かけて実はモンスターですさあさあゲットそんなことも気に
かけてすごく自然な表情でスマホを触っていますさあ一おっさんに見せかけた
モンスターエナジーに接触するとか
おっと動きがあったアーティスマホ向けてお茶おったわなあはじめおはやし家みんな
さあそして
今号4社が一番メーカーんあなたをしていることですそれは王よつではありませさあ
キャップに超駆け抜けて8 e ま口に運んな
じゃいやちょっと口からそうな意味でてしまった問題が柱
それ知ってるはずねぇ
[音楽]